le parc équestre fédéral de nouveau en
selle pour les jo-2020 tu 4 c'est en
tout cas ce que veulent croire les
défenseurs de la candidature de lamotte
beuvron
car les sites éphémère comme le parc du
château de versailles
retenu pour l'équitation aurait du plomb
dans l aile c'est ce qui ressort d'une
réunion entre emmanuel macron et tony
estanguet
le patron du comité d'organisation
l'équitation sur un grand site
historique
ça relance l'équitation élitiste or
aujourd'hui l'équitation n'est plus un
sport élitiste la fédération française
d'équitation et la troisième fédération
sportive française derrière le football
et le tennis donc très largement
démocrate démocratiser en termes de
nombre de pratiquants et on a ici à la
motte une histoire jeunes mais on a une
histoire c'est la cité des cavaliers ça
plus d'un quart de siècle s'est imprégné
avec les generali open de france
désormais et tous les cavaliers qui sont
dans l'équipe olympique
aujourd'hui ce qu'on était champions
olympiques à rio
bon nombre sont passés par la
motte-beuvron leur première compétition
c'est lamotte beuvron et les arguments
ne manquent pas 100 millions d'euros
d'économies par rapport à versailles une
gare à cinq minutes à pied du site cent
mille places d'hébergement pour le
village olympique à center parc
l'aéroport de châteauroux à proximité et
aussi l'air de la campagne l'avantagent
que l'on a en région sens de la loi et
sur le site du parquet fédéral de
lamotte-beuvron c'est d'avoir de
l'espace cet espace il est important et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
distanciation elle est facile sur les
centaines d'hectares comme on peut la
voir à lamotte beuvron est beaucoup plus
compliqué sur les sites qui seront
beaucoup plus petit et renfermés sur
eux-mêmes
aujourd'hui l'avantagent de lamotte
beuvron on sait qu'on a un site qui
existe avec des équipements qui existent
en partie l'intérêt pour nous
réjouissons de la loi c'est de
construire à la mode levon un site
répondant aux normes internationales et
olympique
si la région est la première en terme de
licenciés en équitation par rapport au
nombre d'habitants
elle devra compter avec la concurrence
d'autres sites prestigieux comme
chantilly ou l'hippodrome d'auteuil